thank you
[Music]
welcome back
to another very serious episode of the
careful boys we have a featured careful
girl here let's give it up for clean
again
careful boys and the careful girls
is that a good b-boy is it good is it
good I love it he loves it I think it's
great that means I don't is that
potential it's already met its potential
all right so it's very interesting we're
gonna have a serious moment we're gonna
have a serious conversation right now
because you know we don't talk about
this kind of stuff a lot but we want to
ask
and check in on how you guys are all
doing
why are you so mad already I just threw
my head off let's talk about it serious
questions we haven't asked how you're
doing we always talk about other people
and other people let's minimize the bits
let's maximize the feelings we're
maximizing the feelings yeah we're
cranking all the way up yep how are you
feeling I know [ __ ] we're friendship
honestly I honestly feel very happy
really excited I feel
uh stop running no I'm serious I feel
like very happy I feel like I'm in a
good place in life right now feel like
I'm very busy with work what's going
good what's going good for you in life
everything
what are the what are what are the the
like if you got a couple of like buckets
or whatever which one's getting filled
up pretty good my work bucket's getting
filled okay busy love and work my
relationships with my friends I feel is
great and my wife you know everything's
good and then you know having that's it
everything's great I have nothing to
complain about right now
nothing to complain about in two months
the rose Parade's coming
don't talk to me in two months dude okay
in two months I'm gonna be [ __ ]
pissed
yeah and then so how did that feel like
is there anything really feel different
honestly I didn't really feel different
I felt the same I felt like I was kind
of expecting
you know well I'll say this since the
pandemic this has been the first
time where I feel like normal again I
feel like kind of back to normal because
so much of my life before the pandemic
was all in the gym and I was working all
the time to completely [ __ ] nothing
at like during the pandemic and then now
I feel like I'm back to kind of like my
old routine and working again so I feel
very excited about it but the only
difference is you have like 11 000 more
followers on IG now yeah that's cool
that's really cool you're a real one
dude no I appreciate it's cool that's
that's a cool thing but it's uh yeah I'm
just happy to be working again that's it
I'm just losing followers
but you also gain a bunch too really but
you're also toxic yeah they call me yeah
yeah that's what kids call you yeah the
kids why do you think people want to
follow you is it Geo maybe I'm boring I
don't know like all this guy does is do
squats every day oh yeah he loves this
kid yeah yeah dude all this guy does is
show his fat tits all the time oh that's
all it is you know I know it's not about
you right now but the amount of work and
time you put into your IG stories I'm
like dude if you just did that to your
feet you'd probably be way more famous
but other than that like back to Nick
you don't think Bar's not famous Bart's
famous no Barcelona videos all this
combined minus most of us it's believed
by this one
friend
I didn't hear that I heard a friend and
I heard I heard friend and I heard it
dubbed yeah actually which is weird yeah
I'm thankful for you for all you guys as
well it was weird
he's like how am I gonna bleep that out
of the social media like I said duck I
heard it was not going on tick tock
speaking of Ryan how are you Ryan damn
it dude I think I'm okay I I thought
about it recently and I think for a
while I started to feel a little bit sad
that like
you I think when you get to your late
30s get ready for this you you really
start to notice that uh you just look a
lot different to yourself in the mirror
faster so like between 30 and 35 I think
that's kind of like a nice age to be but
once you're like 36 to 39 within those
three years your reflection changes a
time like you just go oh oh that's me
now okay is it because you look further
away from like like 25 or something you
know what it is it's half you're aging
quicker and half you don't look in the
mirror as often you just don't check
yourself out as much and so when you do
you it's like the increments the
increments are just like larger you know
like when you don't see someone for a
long time and oh you grew so much it's
like the opposite of that you just go oh
wow that's what you look like now on you
piece of [ __ ] but it's like uh but then
I started to realize it's fine like uh I
realized that the age I'm at now is
um it's the age my dad was once I gained
sentience of life like when I was like
four and I realized who my dad was and
what my life was my dad was this age and
it trips me out and I'm like wow okay I
think that's pretty cool interesting
perspective yeah because to me I think
at that age my dad was in he looked like
a dad like he looked you know like like
older grown man or whatever and I'm like
oh that's cool that I don't specifically
I feel younger yeah like I don't I don't
feel old but for my age I'm like I
should when I look at all my friends
that I grew up with I'm like they look
like you know they're my supervisors at
work or some [ __ ] and look like how you
thought you're dead they look like how I
thought I should look like let's be
stereotypical though dancers are in a
different boat right like not only are
you drinking the [ __ ] Fountain of
Youth every day but just culturally it's
you know you're just constantly hip and
and forward thinking and am I speaking
about myself maybe I like that he's like
I just can't help it
am I protecting my own future
insecurities I don't know am I
projecting my insecurities looking for
companionship and then hearing the void
yeah perhaps perhaps more than likely
it's nice to rather than be you know I'm
constantly hip versus having constant
hip problems do you do that with
yourself pretty regularly what's that do
you do these check-ins with this I
didn't used to I think that's what's
different is that like I didn't I never
thought about it it's very autonomous
because like I've been used to looking
pretty young in my mid-30s like I was so
used to people always going like oh my
God you're 30. oh you're 31. it just
kept going and I think now it's like oh
you're 39 I thought you were 33 like
it's something that's not that far off
you look like you're 28. yeah I would
still guess you're 28. thank you but uh
it's not as important to me anymore it
used to be where I was like I felt like
oh [ __ ] the day that I look my age I'm
gonna be really sad I braced myself and
I got there and I'm like it's cool
because it is a part of your identity
right as far as like everyone always
telling you like oh you look so young
speaking of part of your identity though
from far away from not being as close to
Ryan like a long time ago his hair was a
part of his identity yeah like the whole
right anime thing and having like
[ __ ] like Final Fantasy style hair
and being able to have it be Immaculate
and
your hair still is immaculate you can't
you sometimes you come in here I mean
I'm just happy to have here bro like
that's it I'm just grateful hey [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my God Steve hates Ryan oh my God
Steve really needs friends is your
insecurity speaking out and filling a
voice uh no I'll get it it's like in
fact yeah maybe if it was like 20 years
ago and you can't do [ __ ] about it I
plan on getting that thing where they
take care from the back of here and they
put it up here like fine but you kind of
have to
we do not have more hair up here than
like I want right now I want I want
mother nature to take effect because it
like I want to be able to do it quicker
but they they want you to have most of
the damage done already so that once you
do it it's like set and then you can
just [ __ ] attack so you're in like
your own self-described limbo exactly
it's annoying because because I've been
using like this like regenerative hair
stuff
um product stuff for years and it's
actually like worked pretty well it's
not great because like especially under
these [ __ ] lights
um like you know what I mean you you
just are able to see like more of like
what's going on I don't know that dude
don't hold that I don't give [ __ ]
honestly let's go baby that's some Dome
yeah it's but it's like yeah I got it's
like oh whatever you know you can kind
of see what's going on with it right but
like I kind of gotta wait because
unfortunately I just still have too much
of it in the front so yeah I gotta kinda
it's coming baby it's coming you're like
close to like uh like old martial arts
Kung Fu Master you you just shave your
front half and braid the rest yeah dude
I'll get there I'll get the Iron Monkey
s
so yeah but it's just like a waiting
game with that and then um
as far as other [ __ ] though I just like
I think my grandma's about to go so that
sucks just found out about that I mean
she's 94 right and but one of the
funniest things that happens with with
that especially that age you tell
someone your grandma's about to go how
old is she 94. oh yeah okay
it's still your grandma dude it's like
like well she deserves it that should
have happened a long time ago yeah I
think it's past due she's lucky yeah but
like she's reached a point where like um
so my mom like takes care of her and
stuff I've talked about this before but
like my grandma now starts to call my
mom mommy oh yeah usually she's been a
tough bird like forever and like she's
had her mental facilities and all that
kind of stuff but now it's kind of going
pretty quickly so it's it's not looking
great so it's kind of one of those
things dude many people go through way
worse stuff right I can't believe I've
had my grandma this long yeah like I I
never even knew my other Grandma the
green Grandma never know are so having
my grandma is unbelievable but yeah it
just it's a it's just a bummer but I'm
very thankful my mom survived breast
cancer last year very happy about that
and then again this is the this is the
convenience side of me like I have to
basically apologize for like it's like I
know that I'm bleeding on you guys but I
promise you it like it's all good but
like it just sucks right it just sucks
this episode is brought to you by
DraftKings NBA fans the wait is over
basketball is back so tip off the season
with DraftKings Sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the NBA new
customers can make any five dollar NBA
moneyline bet and get 200 in free bets
if your team wins check this out in
addition to the usual bets everyone can
boost their winnings up to 100 with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
go to draftkingsportsbook app opt-in and
place a stepped up same game parlay
today with payouts bigger than ever
drafting Sportsbook is where I go to bed
on the NBA well I'm excited to see the
Lakers he's gonna move to Vegas my heart
is here with LA of course so I'm excited
to see what the late how the Lakers do
I've also seen in some of the preseason
the Warriors are going crazy so they're
also my Cali peeps so got a rep for
McCallie Lakers and Warriors download
the drafting Sportsbook app now use
promo code off the Record make any five
dollar bet this week and get 200 in free
bets if your team wins only at draftking
Sportsbook with promo code off the
Record minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details so for sure yeah for sure it's
weird I just found out about this like
like 72 hours ago oh damn yeah so is
where it is mate part of it yeah it's
part of it have you had other uh other
family members passed away because the
old age
um I had my uncle who died of AIDS to
talk about a bunch do a lot of bits
about that
um
had my uh that's always in your type 5
yeah my grandfather went like five years
ago but that you know not really we've
been lucky so it's just will you close
your grandma or are you closer yeah I
love my grandma love her she's such a
tough chick man like I always like to
tell a story because like you know
Everyone likes to talk about people who
are World War II like like went through
the Great Depression and stuff and
people always talk about women of that
era and how like you know subjugated
they were by their man or whatever
[ __ ] my grandma would not take [ __ ]
from anybody dude like ever
um so
so like one of my favorite stories is my
grandma she was um
she heard my grandpa like [ __ ] around
and in the bedroom and she's like what
the hell are you doing in their dick and
like he's like God damn son of a [ __ ]
or whatever and she like goes in there
and um he's he this drawer he's trying
to like pull this drawer out but it's
like stuck and he can't [ __ ] pull it
out and she like comes up to him and my
grandma told my mother she's like if a
man ever puts hands on you ever one time
like puts hands on you you [ __ ] leave
right so my grandpa's pulling this shelf
and my grandma comes up my hand like
what's going on today and he finally
like it comes out and he like elbows her
and then she immediately turns around
goes to the closet takes out a suitcase
puts it on the bed and she's like
[ __ ] certain loading clothes in there
and he's like Freda what the [ __ ] is
going on and she's like she's like you
know my mother said he put [ __ ] hands
on me I swear to God he was like free I
didn't even [ __ ] know you were there
what that she's like yeah yeah you
[ __ ] hell on me I can't believe this
[ __ ]
a great woman honestly so how do you
Rectify it I reckify what that oh he
just explained like ah this drawer was
just a mistake yeah yeah but she doesn't
know because he's just gesturing over
here and she's just hearing she's angry
already so then all she knows is she
comes up behind him and he [ __ ] like
hit her with his elbows just no it's
just a collateral damage but yeah but
then she she's laughing telling us that
story right so like it's great but but
yeah it's just one of those things where
I'm very glad that I had
a strong woman raised my mother who's
the strongest [ __ ] woman and um yeah
just I feel lucky that especially
because like growing up I had my mother
and I had my really hot sister
good Lord to look up to strong women
here yeah a lot of strong women around
me at all times so I just feel very a
lot of tens yeah a lot of tens yeah well
thank you for sharing yeah of course
but I'm good otherwise oh come out of
the pandemic though man gotta say I miss
people a lot glad that I had this room
honestly this room was a Saving Grace
for me for sure because like like all
you boys because like uh pandemic is
hard for like social people like [ __ ]
it's hard but yeah it is what it is I
know people had a way worse so again
there you go me apologizing for um
feeling everything for feeling
apologizing for feelings yeah you can't
have any fun how are you how are you
Colleen how are you I would say the the
short answer is overall good I don't
have anything immediate to complain
about there are things make something
more of what make something up make
something up take something up to
complain about to make anything up
um but I will say this I I do feel
stagnant creatively
I feel
I met in
um some of my relationships in my life
um so I'm seeking just different
perspectives and different ways of
experiencing life so Ayahuasca
absolutely oh yeah you're interested in
that maybe maybe one day what about some
mushrooms I've done it have you done my
Alaska part no it just sounds like the
those are the key words that those
Ayahuasca Retreats oh stagnation yeah
you feel stagnant or you want to better
your relationship come here and trip
balls for five days
come here and trip balls there needs to
be a little more intention behind it
[ __ ] pants
that's a good place to start yeah that's
that's pretty good yeah just trying to
meet new people who have maybe different
lives than I or different experiences
that I do right because you typically
surround yourself with people who do
similar things that you do so it tends
to get stagnant the conversations tend
to get stagnant or the experiences do so
oh it's all you need new friends yeah I
do I do that's why you're hanging with
us huh absolutely I do you are welcome
here whenever Joe's gone
everything else you gotta ask these guys
I'm not I don't make those calls sure we
don't know we get our pay cut how are
you buddy yeah Anthony oh man
um you know what's interesting I think
um as like a more grown adult now
obviously overall things are pretty good
uh now let's get past that I think as an
adult now like for example back in 2008
during like the last kind of like
recession and like things were tough
like I was still I just graduated
college I had this Veil over my eyes you
know and about like [ __ ] everything is
possible so you don't really focus on
like any of that stuff you're not like
mature enough you're not experienced
enough you're not like working with like
larger assets like everything that you
have is very like you know
small minded I feel now uh is one of my
first times truly understanding
especially as an adult like the impacts
of things like a recession so things are
definitely more complicated we joke
around about things like pay cuts here
but like you know this is this is one of
the things all of us do things outside
of here and they're like you know put
enough things that add up from like
indirectly or directly from the
recession and you're recognizing all the
time you're like oh things are tougher
now you know what I mean yeah you're
just I'm so happy you know I mean I'm
still like very thankful gratuitous all
those reasons why you keep yourself
going in in the day and [ __ ] like that
trying to stay motivated and disciplined
but overall you realize you know like uh
gigs fall through more work
opportunities aren't showing up you know
what I mean negotiations don't fly as
well or you have less negotiating power
for different things
um so it's just a a more uh you know
volatile and volatile you know there's
less secure before you might put
together like a plan for your business
that you can see anywhere from six to 12
to like two years out you know what I
mean three year game plan nowadays like
you know realistically and still
randomly feeling comfortable about it
maybe it's an LA thing but like I feel
like my schedule I can't see past three
months because it can change any time or
whatever yeah which is a little bit of a
maybe it's a new normalcy that I feel a
weird comfort with it or maybe I know
other people in my own industry or
circles are feeling the same thing so in
that same way like I'm sorry people I'm
sure people have it worse so you just
don't complain anymore yeah you know
seriously yeah but like I I'm now
definitely starting like as we keep
rolling into like you know interest
rates inflation you know recession
conversations things that we even bring
up here at the news table those are
things that affect us like on our daily
life even to a smaller even even to like
gas prices right but when it kind of
slowly starts affecting everything and
again from a business point of view
we're definitely affected you know what
I mean
um it's I can't not acknowledge that
it's a more stressful time are you
scared about it no I I mean I'm fine I
think we've all I mean if our parents
have endured worse I feel like we're
gonna be fine right like I didn't
immigrate here from a war you know what
I'm saying like I feel no matter what I
can't [ __ ] complain in a good way
yeah right
um so like I feel like no matter what
we'll make it through I don't know what
the outcome of it is but like those
uh at once maybe when I was younger a
little bit more naive but a little bit
more like optimistic about things I feel
like a lot of those visions and dreams
have rationalized a bit and sometimes
some of that childlike Wonder being gone
is a bad thing yeah sometimes I think
it's healthy and realistic but I feel
like I'm we're I'm in that phase of life
right now things are um hardening things
are starting to like really kind of
confirm and validate themselves as like
the realism of the world and stuff I'm
not becoming more cynical but I'm
becoming more realistic about certain
things and trying to readjust my dreams
according to what's really you know
reachable so yeah kind of a interesting
time so well spoken you or anything it's
very articulate very articular yeah so
that wraps it up we did everybody uh did
we miss anybody I don't think so
um unless somebody lied
Bart I didn't lie or unless somebody
went first and what kept it all positive
only yeah
say anything everyone Joe's not here
buddy you can keep it real yeah I mean I
keep a real joke he's not gonna call you
out anymore you know what I mean we got
your back I think for me
um
it's an interesting point in my life
that I've never felt before
because I think in like uh
in your first like maybe like in their
20s you're kind of figuring out yourself
right early 20s
and then for me I was pretty fortunate
where I met Joe and we like knew what
our passion was so that was like late
20s and we just kind of pushed hard and
it's it's really about focusing on
yourself and what you got going on
because your parents are they're older
but they're not in a time where you need
to take care of them and then so you
kind of just build this life right so if
you get married you have a kid and
you're just kind of like okay cool this
is the life that I created the
interesting point I have in my life now
is my parents are coming back into the
picture more and more together well my
mom just kicked my dad out again it's
not even another off director oh that's
good
the story is so good so now it's at a
point where it's like uh it's a really
weird power struggle because now it's
like they look to me of what they should
do
and so now it's like instead of being
able to just kind of focus on the family
that I want to create I'm like oh this
is like this is the start of the the
burden era where like you gotta like
it's a good name you know when you gotta
like it's like oh we got to bring extra
diapers because Dad's gonna [ __ ] them
himself when you go to Yosemite you know
like you got like you gotta start
thinking like we're like the Young The
Young bird has to like take the old bird
in you know so it's like I'm just like
oh [ __ ] I don't know if I was ready for
this you're the [ __ ] slab of cement
in between two bricks two hard ass
Bricks now you gotta keep everything
together so I'm like oh [ __ ] now this is
like even more things that I didn't
think I had to worry about so soon
but it came like pretty abruptly from
like even my dad moving to Vegas and
then going I don't really like it here
moving back here I want to move in with
your mom and then my mom's like all
right finally we can try to give it a
try we'll be cohabitants and then not
get this [ __ ] out of here like
all of that happened in like [ __ ]
three months six months
so now I'm like I thought I was just I
just gotta focus on Barbara McCain and
Just Kidding Films as if it's a nice
life you know but then now there's like
all this other stuff that I was like oh
[ __ ] this is crazy so did you give your
dad a pay cut I want to diaper cut yeah
[Music]
[Music]